april is earth month a time to celebrate
our commitment to the natural world
our behavior impacts so many species on
this planet
and it's even threatening the habitats
that we humans call home believe me i've
seen it this island and this beach went
out 200 feet just five years ago so my
family and i are hitting the road do you
guys know the mating call of a manatee
to help rebuild our tree welcome to our
chestnut tree repair this is a solar
powered electric powered beach cleaning
robot and get a firsthand look at what
it takes to save the planet you're about
to enter the largest vertical farm in
the world yes what
we meet up with national geographic
explorers across the country to learn
more about solutions we have to really
save our big trees we can't just plant a
little tree and say it's okay to cut
down the big trees we gotta really save
these senior citizens as i call them
from the trees i love living at the tops
of the trees i feel like we should stay
here gotta get the boys up here next to
the seas
and everywhere in between the tent is up
we
are tired enough to sleep in it
adrian on board
really good miles pushing through
my husband ben who's more comfortable on
a busy city street than in a forest
everyone's making fun of this hat but
let me tell you something i'm going to
be the only one
without a sunburned neck
and me leading the way through this epic
eco adventure all in the name of science
go mommy go go mommy go
i'm ginger z chief meteorologist at abc
news buckle up because you're coming
with us in search of solutions
we're branching out
[Music]
you